cutra said I'm mischaracterizing science
I don't think I made any claims about
the activity of what science is all
[Music]
about I was in the US last week debating
with the theoretical physicist Sean
Carroll and he speaks very confidently
he says we know from physics that there
is no strong emergence and so everything
including Consciousness and Free Will
must be reducible uh you must be just
weak emergence only weak emergence it's
interesting to me that it seems that
both me and SRA are perhaps disagreeing
with she can correct me if perhaps
disagreeing with SH Cal in different
ways I disagree with him because I don't
think conscious we can make sense of
Consciousness being weakly emergent
suchitra is disagreeing with him I think
on empirical grounds and I have actually
heard I tried to talk to scientists as
much as possible that the the physicists
it's the theoretical physicists who
don't do experiments who sit with their
equations who think oh everything's
reducible to the B basic equations of
quantum mechanics whereas the condensed
metaphysicist like chitra uh who
actually do the experiments and study
these systems know that is false but
Consciousness is not a mechanical
property and not a mechanical behavioral
property when I say my wife's in pain
I'm not making a claim about her
behavior or the behavior of her inner
parts I'm making a claim about how she
feels now it's closely connected to
behavior because when you feel pain you
sort of scream and stuff but it's not
just a claim about behavior and so this
whole Paradigm of weak emergence just
just falls apart so that's the question
if you're thinking does physicalism make
sense is it plausible you've got to ask
yourself is it plausible that
Consciousness is just a mechanical
behavioral property because that's what
the physicalists think maybe I could
just say very briefly that the story the
pans sists tell which comes from Russell
so Russell in the 1920s was thinking
very hard about the fact that physics is
purely mathematical and what he realized
follows from that is that physics isn't
really telling us that much about
fundamental reality it's merely
describing its mathematical structure so
as far as physics is concerned
fundamental reality could be anything as
long as it has the right mathematical
structure that's all physics requires as
structure you're going to get physics
out of that so the pans psychist
exploits that to make sense of the
emergence of physical reality so the
idea is at the fundamental level of
reality we've got these networks of very
simple conscious entities interacting in
simple predictable ways forming certain
patterns certain mathematical structures
and those mathematical structures just
are what we call physics I think science
is being mischaracterized here so uh
science is not about mathematical
structures that give rise to reality so
the best theories we have can maybe you
know talk about like I mentioned two
electrons we break it down we get quarks
we break it down to something more
fundamental no one would argue that can
explain any of the reality we encounter
whether it be you know phen Quantum
phenomena I study like superc
conductivity whether it be classical
phenomena like um um waterfalls or um
you know anything else that we um
encounter that's that's around us
volcano waterfalls whatever it is you
don't start from a mathematical
structure and get to that you don't get
to Quantum Behavior you don't get to
classical Behavior it's about
empirically encountering what we do and
then making a phenomenological model or
assertion to try and explain what we see
and it's useful because it can it has
some predictive power to say okay if I
change this thing I can build a bridge I
can make a Quantum phenomena change a
bit I can use super conductivity but is
it a mathematical structure that tells
us is about reality absolutely not
that's not what science is about and
actually the so-called laws which
Science is based on where we say oh
science means that we have Newton's Laws
we have Maxwell's laws these dictate How
the Universe behaves that's not what
science does what Newton's law is that
you know can app or fell that's gravity
it's empirically describing what is
observed and from that we say these two
things are connected to each other and
what is supposedly this mathematical
structure that underlies it is near a
description where we're saying we're
describing what's around us we can
connect these two things and by the
connection that's useful because it
helps us connect other things it is
absolutely not building a fundamental
framework to describe anything around us
we have to experimentally encounter it
SRA said I'm mischaracterizing science I
don't think I made any claims about the
activity of what science is all about I
I'm interested in
ontology trying to have our best guess
at the nature of reality and that should
be scientifically informed but I think
that's a philosophical project which
involves identifying having our best
guess at what is going on at the
fundamental level what is weakly
emerging from that what is strongly
emerging on that and different
scientists different philosophers have
different views as I've said the
physicist Sean Carol thinks everything's
weakly emergent on basic quantum
mechanics suchitra seems to have a very
different strongly emerging story uh
Hillary Rejects the idea that there's
any unique way of carving up the world
so we can't just look at the oh what are
scientists doing that'll tell us you've
got to have scientifically informed
philosophy and I think you know we've
very much in our generation forgotten
the the the role of philosophy here in
synthesizing science and other things we
know about reality you may have seen
this last week that over a hundred
scientists and philosophers jointly
co-signed a letter which said that the
view you're describing here is what they
call pseudo science
they there he is again he's got to seem
like he's impartial right got to do do
both of them so they think that your
your view posits magic that it's
unscientific because it can never be
tested and they're Fed Up of seeing in
at events like this and in popular
newspapers and magazines this view of
strongly emerging pans psychism being
treated as if it might be a scientific
theory or integrated information Theory
I will want to come do you want to
respon this is it sign I have to correct
correct how you portrayed that to
continue watching this video click the
link in the top left or in the
description below or visit I a.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas